I greet ramicus Belgian TV Wow you look
stunning as always thank you you made it
miss a fantastic character now I'd like
to ask looking back at your career is
this everything or more or less that
Hollywood has never brought you well
sometimes you're ready to take a role
with by the teeth really and having
worked so long and intensively in in
theatre it felt to me like a synthesis
of my work on stage and my work on the
screen you know and these opportunities
don't come around every day so I
relished it and you know
yes peril Rafi News congratulations
reports I think any girl I have to say
they all had to go back at midnight
everything had to go back it was um yeah
it was I think the the entire costume
budget was less than the ER mayor's bag
which was also borrowed so it was very
simple but Susie Benzino her work on the
film was extraordinary and for me it's
such a fruitful and creative
relationship one has with the costume
designer because often this very I don't
think this Woody Allen's films are only
any different but I think that um
there's very little rehearsal time often
on the film and so it's a very fruitful
experience with a costume design and
when you get to try things on and and
begin to walk around in the character's
shoes literally hi
is it wow that's pretty
[Music]
good question this one certainly took me
by surprise you know I threw myself at
the roll and and whenever you do that
you always your bit sort of nervous and
trepidatious about the result because
you you're part
unconscious when you're working when
you're working deeply but it's always a
thrill and particularly because I've
been away from the film industry for so
long working at the Sydney Theatre
Company it's nice to think that you know
I've got a film career to return to so
I'm excited more than anything actually
thank you very much
[Applause]